it's been a little over two years since
apple released their mac pro and at the
time that was an extremely powerful
machine but now we have something brand
new of course the mac studio with the
insane m1 ultra chip yes two l1 maxes
put together and in this video we are
going to answer an important question
just how badly is the new mac studio
destroying the mac pro and to do that
we're going to be comparing a ton of
different benchmarks yes there's video
editing but we're also doing a lot of
stuff like music production with logic
we're doing programming with xcode photo
editing rendering blender all these
different tests to show you guys just
how crazy this new mac studio is now
before we begin i do want to mention the
difference in prices we bought the 15
000
mac pro that's with the burner card for
pro res
and that's insane because this thing
starts at 4 grand and this is actually
configured to the max in terms of
performance it comes with the 64 core
gpu it comes with a massive 128 gigs of
unified memory and it has the same one
terabyte ssd that the mac pro has so
that's 5800 compared to 15
000 just two years later and these
scores are going to blow your mind but
before we get into the benchmarks i do
want to mention some of the big
differences between the mac pro and the
mac studio of course this mac studio is
so small that you could literally throw
it into your backpack there's actually a
carrying case for this whereas the mac
pro there's no way that you're carrying
that anywhere it's just so heavy and
hard to move and in terms of the io this
is actually very impressive we got six
total thunderbolt 4 ports you even have
an sd card slot which the mac pro does
not come with you've got a couple of usb
type a's you got hdmi you got 10 gb
ethernet you have literally everything
that you need right here and i know that
you can get even more thunderbolt ports
with extra gpu modules in the mac pro
but i don't think that many people need
it but there are some who will and of
course you can get a lot more gpu
performance with the mac pro because you
have crazy amd graphics options but i
mean you're spending a ton
of money compared to this 5800 machine
now before we jump into the benchmarks i
want to do a quick shout out to our
brand new m1 ultra soc packaged t-shirt
you got the subtle ultra text in the
back you got the soc package you got the
ram the dye everything built in so
you'll find it down in the merge shelf
below and please use the promo code m1
ultra for 20 off all of our merch but
with that said let's jump into the
benchmark starting off with geekbench
5's single core cpu test and right here
you can see that the max studio is
actually 60
faster in terms of the single core now
that might not seem like a big deal but
it actually is for a lot of common tasks
especially like web browsing where we
have our speedometer 2 benchmark we're
getting 300 points with the m1 ultra mac
studio compared to 137
with the mac pro that's basically three
times faster or snappier for web
browsing and believe me when i tell you
this you actually feel it day to day
this is just so incredibly snappy just
bam going through all the websites
whereas you do feel a little bit of lag
on the mac pro and it's just so annoying
and now moving on to the multi-core i do
want to mention that our mac pro is
fitted with a 12 core xeon so in terms
of the multi-core performance the max
studio with the m1 ultra is 92
faster so there's a big jump there and
before i get into all the graphics
testing i do want to focus on the cpu
first and that brings us to cinebench
r23 now compared to the 12 core xeon in
the mac pro the m1 ultra is 70
faster which is really good but i do
want to make a point that it looks like
cinebench is not fully optimized for
apple silicon because it's not pushing
the m1 ultra chip to the max for example
it's only using up to 58 watts peak
power compared to some other apps that i
tested later on in this video that hit
up to 68 watts so it's not fully pushing
the cpu like it should and the really
important point that i want to make is
that with this m1 ultra taking up to 58
watts of peak power the mac pro with the
12 core xeon actually went over 200
watts peak power that's close to four
times more peak power in cinebench and
it's crazy that it's getting that much
better performance and now moving on to
the real world cpu tasks that you guys
are going to be doing on the daily let's
first start off with programming in
xcode now of course we have the xcode
benchmark that maxim eramenko made for
us and i'll link that down in the
description
but in terms of the performance this
thing finished in 69 seconds that's
basically a world record score
for that test compared to 125
with that mac pro and apparently even
the best 28 core xeon mac pro finished
in 90 seconds so this thing right here
is literally the best mac ever made for
programming and it might even be the
best for pc programming as well like
compiling mozilla firefox or whatever
tests you can do on pc as well but we're
gonna test that later on but this makes
it 81 faster than the mac pro and now
moving on to music production with logic
pro there's also a stress test benchmark
where it pushes as many tracks as it can
before overloading the cpu and i do want
to mention that intel's xeon chips have
always been really really good at logic
because they're very stable with that
ecc memory but we ran the test and the
m1 ultra is actually 50
faster or it loads up 50 percent more
tracks
than the mac pro 341 compared to 227
so i mean this thing's gonna be overkill
for like almost anybody and the nice
thing is that if you need a lot of ram
for the music production plugins you can
get up to 128 gigs of unified memory so
everything is going to work incredibly
fast and now let's get into some photo
editing and the first thing i want to
test is the affinity photo benchmark now
that app is actually properly optimized
for apple silicon and it's showing some
insane gains for the m1 ultra first of
all in the combined cpu benchmark test
it got
1888 points compared to only
867 with the mac pro that's 2.2 times
faster that is just incredible
definitely killing it but check out the
combined single gpu test this thing got
36 526
compared to
7260 with the mac pro that is literally
five times better gpu performance and
the main reason for that is because of
the unified memory it's able to load
everything up so quickly without having
to hand it over between the cpu gpu like
on the traditional x86 mac pro so it's
getting everything done
insanely fast in that test but now
pivoting over to a much more popular app
we have adobe's lightroom classic and
what we did is we exported 50 raw images
with a bunch of effects and other stuff
added to it and this is where we got
57 faster performance on the m1 ultra
mac studio only 45 seconds compared to a
minute and 11 seconds on the mac pro and
this is a big deal because
on the m1 max macbook pro this is the
test where it could not beat out the mac
pro while it beat it out and a lot of
other stuff so we are getting some
really really good performance with
these m1 ultra and it's just crazy that
for 5 800
you're just stomping the mac pro for 15
grand so this is really good news and
now with all the cpu benchmarks out of
the way let's go ahead and move over to
the graphics side of things and the
first thing i want to discuss is
geekbench 5's metal test where this m1
ultra got a little bit faster than the
vega 2. now that might not make sense
because it should be a lot faster
theoretically and the reason for that is
because geekbench has just such short
bursts of tasks
that
this m1 ultra handles it so quickly that
the system ends up just not giving it
the full performance or the full wattage
because these tests are so easy so
that's why it gets very low geekbench 5
metal scores so to show you the true
performance let's actually run a gaming
benchmark that fully utilizes a cpu or
at least we think it does we have gfx
benches aztec ruins 1440p off-screen
test and here the m1 ultra is now 2.36
times faster than the vega 2 graphics
card in the mac pro and that is more
like it and that is more in line with
the performance that we were seeing in a
lot of the other tests that i'm going to
get into in just a minute and some of
the crazy differences that i noticed was
actually in blender doing 3d rendering
but before i get into that let's
actually get into some video editing
with final cut pro in our standard 5
minute 4k
h.264 x port the m1 ultra mac studio
finished 38 seconds faster than the mac
pro and to be honest i'm kind of
disappointed with this test and it kind
of seems like that extra m1 max chip
that has all the extra
regular video encoders and decoders it
seems like those are not working for
some reason and it might be because
apple has a pre-release version of final
cut pro that they gave to early
reviewers of the mac studio but they
have not released that new version which
is extremely annoying i mean apple
please ship this stuff with your new
hardware like we want that new version
but we don't have it and it seems like
it is just not utilizing it because this
score is not that impressive compared to
the mac pro but if we move over to hevc
one minute stabilization it is twice as
fast compared to the mac pro which is
good but it's actually not that much
faster compared to the m1 max and we'll
show you that in our upcoming video when
we compare
this thing to the macbook pro but now
getting into some of the very heavy
hitting codecs like 8k red raw to uhd
we're getting around 48
faster export times with the m1 ultra
that's five minutes 25 seconds compared
to eight minutes and two with the mac
pro and this is only a five minute
export imagine exporting like a one hour
long red video you're saving a ton of
time so that's very nice now if we
actually take this same clip and we
export it to prores 422 instead
for some reason we're not getting as
good of performance it goes down to 5
minutes 40 seconds compared to 7 minutes
40 but it is still quite a bit faster
and it's shocking because you know
you're saving so much money but i am
just getting started with these scores
because the rest of these tests are
insane check this out we have a five
minute 4k pro res raw to prores 422 and
we are getting some insane results only
41 seconds on the m1 ultra compared to a
minute and 45 with the mac pro and the
big point that i want to make is that
that mac pro has the after burner card
which is meant to encode and decode
prores this actually comes with
prores
encoders and decoders built in for free
you don't have to buy an extra card so
this is just so nice especially for the
price difference but this next test
totally blew my mind we are exporting 8k
prores raw to prores 422 and the m1
ultramax studio only took two minutes
and 43 seconds compared to 12 minutes
and 50 seconds with afterburner and this
is what you want to buy if you're doing
any of that 8k prores stuff because
you're getting all of those extra prores
encoders and decoders once again built
in for free but here's the catch what if
you take out that afterburner card from
the mac pro what score are you gonna get
well
20 minutes and 18 seconds without the
after burner this blows my mind like
this is almost 18 19 times faster than
the mac pro so i honestly think this is
the best video editing computer out
there right now simply because of those
media engines and now of course not
everybody uses prores and not everybody
uses the standard h.264 codec so i also
threw in an hevc h.265
codec test as well because that is
becoming a lot more popular so it's a
five minute export eight bit and this
thing finished in one minute and 17
seconds compared to two and a half
minutes with the mac pro that's
essentially twice as fast
and that is just
absolutely insane that within two years
apple just completely annihilated their
old mac pro like i think you're gonna
have to be crazy to buy that thing
unless you need the highest end graphics
chips or you need like a terabyte and a
half of ram for some scientific
crazy tasks but honestly for
99 of the people this thing is going to
give you insane performance in the
common tasks that people actually do now
before i move on to 3d blender rendering
i do want to mention that we're going to
be doing a full video editing comparison
video which is also going to be editing
playback performance so not just exports
but we're also going to add davinci
resolve 17 performance and premiere pro
so it's going to be a complete video
editing video for all of you guys out
there who are curious on that and now
with that said let's move on to 3d
rendering and the first test we're going
to be doing is blender party tug with
the ev engine that's kind of like for
previews this m1 ultra finished in only
4.49 seconds compared to 32.95
with the mac pro now this is really
weird because the gaming performance is
only about two times faster but in this
test it is
what's like six seven times faster and
the reason for that is because we have
the unified memory architecture so
instead of copying data back and forth
between the cpu gpu whatever the ram
it's doing it all in house in one
massive m1 ultra package so it's
extremely efficient and we're just
getting a major difference here and now
let's move on to the real renderer the
cycles render for high quality exports
and renders the first thing we're going
to do is party tug with cycles and here
the m1 ultra finish in one minute 22
seconds compared to 152 with the mac pro
that is only 36 faster i mean i say only
but it is actually a pretty good
difference but i was expecting more out
of the m1 ultra and the reason we're not
getting crazy insane performance is
because render was updated with apple
silicon support but it was only kind of
patched up to make it work in reality
the actual engine or the back end engine
has not fully been redone for apple
silicon it's kind of like a
compatibility layer it's kind of like
using crossover to play x86 games on mac
os apple silicon it's kind of doing some
translation so it's not the full
performance that we should be expecting
hopefully this fall when apple and the
blender team give us a true
metal rendering engine with that said
let's move on to the next test we have
the bmw cycles gpu test and here we have
33.5 seconds for the m1 ultra compared
to
43.8 that is 30 faster and then finally
we have classrooms and we have a minute
and 6.5 seconds on the m1 ultra a minute
and 29 for the mac pro making it 34
faster so if you have very long exports
this is already gonna give you some
really nice extra performance even
before we get the full new metal
rendering engine but if we take a step
back and look at everything that we've
tested in this video comparing a 5800
max studio to a 15 000 mac pro it's safe
to say that apple has completely
killed that mac pro for 99
of the workloads out there for sure
especially in terms of the cpu
performance because i feel like the cpu
is being utilized very very well
especially in tasks like logic pro music
production especially xcode especially
photo editing it is just killing it for
those cpu tests but in terms of the gpu
i am a little bit underwhelmed i feel
like apple hasn't fully optimized it or
fully let us use all of the power that
we should but either way it's still
killing the vega 2 graphics card that's
in the mac pro and that thing's
expensive that's over two grand just for
the gpu alone and you're getting this
entire package with everything and 128
gigs of unified memory for fifty eight
hundred dollars so yeah i mean rip
mac pro that's all i gotta say and if
you guys know this video i would
recommend clicking the circle above to
subscribe because we have a lot of other
comparisons especially that full video
editing comparison video and the
comparison test to the macbook pro
and an rtx 3090 pc that we're going to
be doing very soon so definitely
subscribe and check out one of those two
videos right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]